il y aura des conséquences massive pour
la russie si elle renouvelle son
agression j'entends par là des
conséquences économiques financières et
autres une des options sur la table
isolé moscou de la finance mondiale
comment en coupant la russie du réseau
inter-bancaire swift par lequel
transitent les échanges pas sûr pour
autant que cette solution soit efficace
il existe d'autres systèmes concurrents
que pourrait utiliser la russie cette
option affecterait aussi durement les
entreprises européennes qui commercent
avec l autre sanction envisagée empêcher
l'entrée en fonction du gazoduc north
stream de chair au kremlin un projet qui
risque en plus d'accroître la dépendance
énergétique des européens vis-à-vis de
la russie les états unis le voient comme
un moyen pour moscou d'asphyxié
l'ukraine
mais l'allemagne ali tient pour subvenir
à ses besoins en énergie les états unis
pensent également a gelé leurs
exportations vers la russie washington
voudrait ainsi privé moscou de pièces
détachées nécessaires à la fabrication
de technologies aérospatiales et
d'armement idem pour les téléphones et
ordinateurs made in us est mais aussi
les technologies sud coréenne
washington a également laissé entendre
qu'il pourrait fournir des armes à kiev
en cas de l'agression russe la russie a
d'ores et déjà fait savoir qu'elle ne
ferait aucune concession
sous la pression des états unis
[Musique]